ladies and gentlemen the bridges loin
bow and Jeff
but dad you look upset with the problem
I was just wondering which one of those
categories that Tom Selleck mentioned at
the top of the show we fit into oh yeah
well there's that three of us so that
rules out the couples I could leave oh
but then I don't know we're not co-stars
so we can't do that one with the two of
you I'd be proud to settle for
companions oh isn't that sweet
why did you say something sweet like
that once in a while both
we have been asked to present the award
for visual effects die hard for this
picture the actor Falls harmlessly back
into a blue screen which is replaced by
a special-effects magic with a filmed
background and we see Alan Rickman
hurtling many stories to his death the
nominees Richard endless
a Lazaro rent boats and Ben Morris
did you ever think a car could have a
mind well Ken Ralston Richard Williams
Edward Jones and George Gibbs gave us
one who framed roger rabbit if it fairy
is dangling the dark and with the help
of special lighting and a blue screen
she joins some friends of ours the
nominees Dennis Muren michael mcallister
phil tippett
and chris evans and the Oscar goes to
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
thank you very much this is very special
like to thank the Academy this award
really represents the work of hundreds
of people in England and in America to
put this show together brilliantly
directed by Bob Zemeckis and I'd also
like to thank some of the artists at
Industrial Light & Magic Scott Farrar
Steve Galli
Steve Starkey Wes Takahashi Brad Jarell
and Bill Kimberlin and my wife Robyn and
this award also for all of us I believe
is special because it's also should be
in honor of all the animators and
directors like Tex Avery from the Golden
Age of animation who inspired Roger
Rabbit thank you
the 61st annual Academy Awards continues
with Langevin on the singing and dancing
stars in the movies